[Music]
at first glance the hokavik looks a lot
like any other neighborhood in the
netherlands it's got a restaurant
barbershop theater grocery store and
open green space you can see people
walking around getting groceries and
having
coffee the difference is that this
neighborhood is a facility for people
with severe dementia and everyone else
in it from grocery store cashiers to
barbers to waiters are trained in
dementia care
this model of care has been dubbed a
dementia village
as people continue to live longer around
the world the proportion of older people
in the population will continue to rise
and that means a steep increase in the
number of people with dementia
caring for that population will require
designing environments that help people
feel safe and free even as they lose the
ability to recognize the world around
them and the architects behind dementia
villages think they might have figured
out the formula to do it
so and this is the hulkaway social life
is happening there so you can see it now
that's eloy van gaal one of the hoga
vic's founders dementia it's of course a
brain disease if you look at your life
as a photo album you forget
the the last pictures the last pictures
they fall out of the album and so you
remember the past better when you were
younger and that's a daily challenge for
the individuals
how to live with memory loss
in early stages people with dementia can
live at home looked after by family
friends or home care but they eventually
need full-time care often that care
comes from traditional nursing homes but
those settings can be sterile and
clinical they all dine together in a big
dining area you all have to listen to
the same music at the same time where
you're forced as a person into a program
of the institution there's
not that much attention
towards who are you really what is my
life story who am i what do i prefer to
do during the whole day in any setting
the goal of good dementia care should be
to preserve quality of life as dementia
progresses
in traditional settings like nursing
homes surface level changes are a good
place to start since people with
dementia might perceive dark tiles as
holes floors should be visually
consistent without contrasting patterns
brightly colored doors and handrails
help residents navigate around and
bright dishware has been shown to help
people with alzheimer's eat more food
acoustic ceiling tiles carpeted floors
and soft furniture can absorb noises
that trigger disorientation
glass-fronted cabinets help residents
have a clear line of sight to what's
stored inside and lighting fixtures that
mimic natural light strengthen
resident's circadian rhythms which helps
mitigate sun downing where people with
dementia become confused in the evening
and night
some of the advices about lighting clear
lines
surface patterns and so are based
on institutions
instead of normalizing the environment
all those elements
are essential
but sometimes they are the solution for
an institution
but the hokavik's design solution is
different instead of changing surface
level design to preserve quality of life
for people with dementia they took a
structural approach and designed their
facility to look as much like the
outside world as possible our guiding
principle here is normalcy it's the
vision a normal life for people living
with dementia that starts with lodging
traditional nursing homes keep all of
their residents under one roof but real
households don't typically consist of
dozens of people so the hokavake split
its residents up into small groups of
six or seven recreating the scale of a
single family home inside each resident
has a private room furnished with
personal belongings the units are split
up into different neighborhoods to mimic
dutch cities that residents are used to
the public space the gardens the streets
the squares
they are equally important if you want
to build a community where people live
each neighborhood's public space was
given distinct landscapes and unique
landmarks so people could easily find
their way around and destinations like
the theater barbershop and grocery store
were put in separate buildings
encouraging intentional movement and
intermingling in that public space
these different areas provide multiple
scales of experience and residents are
given the autonomy to safely wander
along that spectrum from very private to
very public space
that autonomy helps further preserve
quality of life people stay in their own
bedroom many people
socialize in the living room but you can
also decide to leave the house because
the front door is open and to walk to
your own private outdoor space your
terrace or balcony or your own garden or
you walk further into the neighbor where
you can mingle
so it's about choice choice choice where
you want to be during the whole day and
with whom
crucially the hulkafix design allows for
a balance of safe design and controlled
risk walkways for example don't have
super high walls to guarantee that no
one falls over you see hand rails
everywhere in institutions the question
is do you need a handrail everywhere or
do you want to provide a walker where
you can walk with two hands on the
walker and make it accessible for the
walker since the hog of egg opened in
2009 dozens of other dementia villages
have opened across the globe but without
ample government funding they can be
prohibitively expensive and there isn't
enough evidence yet to say whether the
dementia village model is better than
traditional models of care the hulk of 8
claims that since they transitioned from
a traditional model to the village the
number of residents on antipsychotic
medication decreased from 50 in 1993 to
just eight to ten percent today and
there have been studies backing up
different features that dementia
villages use one review of the evidence
found that uncrowded small-scale living
resulted in fewer psychiatric symptoms
and behavioral issues among residents
with dementia and that increased
daylight lighting reduced their
behavioral issues and improved spatial
orientation another review found that
outdoor gardens can reduce agitation and
improve quality of life for people with
dementia
but by creating an environment
specifically for people with cognitive
and physical impairments dementia
villages are a fascinating practice in
universal design design that works for
as many people as possible regardless of
their ability and they can teach us
something about where the outside world
falls short
if you design well for normal people
without dementia you design also well
for people with dementia we we forgot
that people with dementia are human
beings with a lot of aspirations and we
forgot that people with dementia are not
patients where you can put them in a
chair and wait until they die they are
people who want to do certain things
during the day they know and they are
happy to have this freedom
[Music]
you